bản thân, nên các bạn hãy kiên nhẫn
theo dõi nhé. Đầu tiên, tên mình là Ian Amla,
hiện tại mình đang học
tại Học viện Công nghệ Thông tin. Học viện này
không nổi tiếng lắm nhưng rất gần
các trường đại học hàng đầu. Về phần hệ thống, mình phải
nói rằng đó là sở thích của mình, bởi vì trong suốt
sự nghiệp và tương lai đầy áp lực, điều
mình biết mỗi ngày là
ngồi trên chiếc ghế này và bật
internet. Đôi khi mình muốn được nghỉ ngơi.
Và một khoản đầu tư cho ngành công nghiệp là có
rất nhiều vấn đề,
đó là những trải nghiệm chúng ta có trong cuộc sống và trong
khách sạn này. Cuối cùng, lập trình viên là
công việc mình luôn mơ ước. Cảm ơn các bạn đã
xem và nếu thích video thì các bạn
biết phải làm gì rồi đấy.